ou
alors qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé un
accident tout bête afin
je raconte pascal sellem dans la rue je
lis j'aime bien ce que au fait j'ai dit
oui je suis arrivé tard à cacher je
montre un travail
[Applaudissements]
mais attention un mobile et u9 laura je
voulais pas bien
je crains à d'accord c'est vous merci
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe mettre
du sable un
reçu c'est quoi
ça brûle les doigts ça brûle les doigts
votre truc
c'est quoi c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
sylla
c'est chez vous habitez en glissade à
chausser allait pas moi
mais alors pourquoi vous mettez tous vos
trucs devant alors avait un droit d'état
n'a jamais je n'avais pas un droit à se
casser la gueule à la
[Musique]
lentille mange appelle les médecins ont
constaté votre état
suite à une assurance qui va prendre en
charge tous les frais je fais cassé mes
lunettes alors parce que comme une faut
que je les change je vais l'écossé puis
on dira que c'est arrivé pendant que je
suis tombé
maintenant
je vais prendre un petit chocolat quand
même pour me remonter non les gens
pensaient
pas ce que je vais pas vous faire payer
le teinturier quand même non je prends
des chocolats ce sera mieux faites moi
une belle belle boîte pour noël et puis
on n'en parle plus
côté daniel c'est vrai qu'il faut
installer mais là c'est nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi moi je vous connais pas cette
fois c'est ce que je fais au métier
quand le métier de cascadeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]